ladies and gentlemen the next time you
see us we will be in Australia under
whelming Australia
you ready mates that's what they say in
Australia right mate and stuff seafood
we're gonna eat some seafood now
shellfish today in warth in Australia
part one we're gonna try some really
different seafood dishes at a
drastically different price points to
find out which one you want worth it
heads fresh seafoods
are my favorite foods are they really
you know how you can have like more than
one favourite cake I've never had kids
can't really speak to that yeah me
neither
we are on our way to the Sydney fish
market it is going to be epic
heard about haven't been there yet just
googled pictures I mean people just
below our show to find out about deeper
the same thing there's a pelican a right
outside our car it's beautiful already
let's go go look in Oh
[Music]
fish head no touching the large coral
trout blue crabs urns clubs the cutest
fish the cuttlefish let me see those
Tigers in the Samba wrong wrong wrong hi
my name is missus you had dolls here we
have different guns voiced asbestos
again city rock whatever you want you
can try it over here so you guys are
sourcing these Pacific oysters from
literally the place that is on the sign
right yeah they are like dealers that we
get the oysters from not all the lot
tastes the same they are from the
different harvest when the new lot come
I try it so I'm better confidence so I
can activate the customer what exactly
they fly off in Bay Pacific oysters well
salt us this in Iraq there are more of a
strong flavored creamy and sweet creamy
and sweet sounds nice yeah year and half
ago the first that I try I really didn't
like it but gradually I loved it and
right now I'm addicted to Oasis you
don't get the texture and the flavor of
Worcester anywhere else and there are
people that really love voices like when
I give them oysters and their facial
expressions you know you know like they
are really enjoying it it makes me happy
to see them happy as well so how many
gonna get gonna get uh you just get two
of each you it's one moister well we're
gonna eat one of many different kinds my
crazy yes you're crazy what you want for
Adam as well though alright
I have never been more excited into my
life than this moment I have to confess
haven't been won over yet yeah seriously
with energy so sad though
which is so good I know and I'm trying
really hard but they are just snot rocks
what's the shot be like this we're gonna
start with the Hoffman Bay twist it and
save it inside besides and then
voila we'll see you does it better hat
now that just doesn't look fabulous
scares me
oh yeah that is the saltiest oyster I've
ever had I'm not disgusted it Just's you
know him one with me I mean when you're
doing an episode about seafood that is
as pure a taste of the sea as I think
we're gonna get you want to go with the
Sydney rock now I'm very curious to see
the differences between these that's the
funnest part about eating oysters is you
get these tight little packages and each
one is gonna be a little bit different
that is very pretty ugly ugly delicious
that's what I think
[Music]
holy Sh
yeah ah that is so Oh whoa that was like
a delicate cheese there's no world where
people's are not ruined the world with
our smog in Ocean Beach amazing ways and
that fresh breeze of air that is that
always perfection
I could eat a dozen of those and that's
the first time I've ever thought that
about an oyster you were an altar boy
now
I think I might be an oyster boy now
birds are going here all right I know
what's up they're always the boys do
yeah it was crazy
I've had a lot of voices in my life the
American ones don't stand a chance of it
I'm sorry
whew that was easily my favorite
location food anything that we've ever
done your show sir alien seafood fest oh
dear don't do that did you know that the
Australian see what industry is about
2.8 billion dollars with a B with a B
four big ones by looking at a atlas of
the world do you know that Australia is
getting to me wait fish oh we're on the
way to the next location which I cannot
imagine we come close to that kind of
experience that we just had thought wow
try as is the premise of the show
my friend savage I'm chef/owner of
serious restaurant serious for us is all
about seafood what we wanted to serve a
service in our minds it was always to be
simple it was to be accessible it was to
be sustainable and not add too many
flavors so it brings out the best in
each piece today's dish that we're going
to have is its live Marin forgive me but
what is a mirror so Marin is Australian
freshwater crayfish the flavour of Marin
is actually quite strong so it can
tolerate other flavours with it we're
going to click the Marin in half we're
going to clean out the head fill it with
a little bit of new marin butter which
we've made from the shells of Marin
place a little bit of salt over it
simply cook it over the charcoal I don't
like cooking just about anything in
water or water really does is reduce the
amount of flavor bring it off the heat
let the residual heat slowly cook the
remainder of the flesh through we're
going to serve it with a yuzu Koshu
sauce yuzu Koshu is a hyper ferment we
have the native herbs which is sort of
bursts of saltiness we're finishing the
dish with a little bit of finger lime
finger lime is an ingredient which is
native to Australia so you've got layers
and sweetmeats al from the finger limes
salty from the hurts it's quite a
delicious dish so we started the day off
a little casual but now we're getting a
little serous that's probably the best
pun you've ever done okay so we're
having some Australian Marin we're
having some Australian garnishes most
having some Australian wine
do you like it well I can't tell if you
like it or not I like it a lot it's
really strong this is the most excited
I've ever been for a dish lady garnishes
meat beauty is just everything
[Applause]
[Music]
that is delightful in a moment I'm gonna
cry this is far superior meat to lobster
maybe it's not quite as tender with the
flavor I've heard yeah sit Oh oh yeah it
is so good you want the Marin flavor and
they doubled up on it you can really see
it come through the little girls of the
finger lime or next level because you
don't taste it until they burst in your
mouth I don't want to finish this cuz
just don't want this end you got some
meat loaves over here
wait there's a port that's for Adam yeah
stop that's Parata look at you you don't
think about our crew our people we can
get him his own we're right those mad
good double marinated Marin surprise
fact here's a fact that I got interested
in while eating it serous and I took the
time to Google it just now lobsters and
other shellfish like the crayfish we
just had start one colour and then turn
another when they're cooked that's
because there are a bunch of different
pigments in the shell of a lobster but
there's one that's called a sex and then
a sexing thing that is the only one
that's stable and he you think if we
threw you in a boiler what color what do
you think would come out there just be a
burst of light that would sear your
retinas name as many cities as you can
in Australia go burn Darwin Sydney
Brisbane Melbourne Alice Springs I also
know where we're going because this trip
was planned for in advance it is
Melbourne by the power of movie magic
you will not have to sit with us for the
next five hours
unfortunately I will
Oh
Melbourne Melbourne Melbourne Melbourne
Melbourne Melbourne we're in Melbourne
so we're on our way right now to the
last even spot what is happening the
chef de cuisine in South Melbourne still
c-cert more for traditional Cantonese
cooking restaurant today we're gonna
introduce the race greenlit my baloney
really abalone is one of the most
serious item Iike me because how it's
caught its hand I've they are actually
harvested about 40 meters down the
seabed on reefs yeah it's a luxury item
the most luxurious seafood you can get
how much is it to order here it can be a
bit pricey it's hundred seventy eight
dollars four hundred grams do we request
like I want one kilogram or I want 100
grams that's correct Julie a lot of
people come in in the day have a sharing
if you're gonna have that follow entree
it's a lot to have and how will you
describe the flavor of abalone I would
say very seafood it's flavor so it's a
whole mouthful we received a life
abalone from our own suppliers we shut
them and then we clean off the guards
you clean off the skirtings after that
bronies been blanched we fill it in the
bag with the stock with oyster sauce in
Chinese wine I know the traditional way
people doing it in to put the abalone
straight in the Papa what we have
realized is that it loses its shape so
what we do is we actually sous-vide slow
cook it so it maintains its shape in the
flavor in its own use so double the
flavor we serve it actually with a
Japanese mushroom itself with two bok
choy very simple very simple very
classic but it's very flavorful why this
is the Mongolian tent that silks it's
usually not for two people but uh I had
to do it you know like I'm not a Chinese
New Year dinner
now we've flown all the way to Melbourne
to try the greenlit abalone and this is
how a gourd should be served in a subtle
classic way like how you now have
preferences on how Gold's should be
served on your food it is awesome that
this is dived for by hand 40 metres down
you basically have to be the ocean
version of an astronaut to do that Phil
do a diver yeah
[Music]
Wow Wow Wow it's pretty good ruler look
has a very satisfying texture it's both
firm but supple something that's like if
you took a scallop and in oyster and you
combine the flavors together
it is crazy that you have this just
solid blob of deliciousness yeah how
often else does that happen in nature
yeah about the nature
I am so contented we're in a 10th video
over just love seafood so man we had
three seafood dishes at two cities which
seafood was the most worth it to you at
its given price here's the deal I had
the best oyster I've ever had at Doyle's
oyster bar at the Sydney fish market I
didn't think Easter's could be that good
but serous the grilled Marin worth it
winner that was really one of the best
sea creature eating experiences I've
ever had my arm is tired can you hold
this my turn so that Bologna was quite a
steep price although it was definitely
worth the experience
Sydney fish market I thought for sure
that I was gonna do that worth it winner
going it but all that being said serious
is also my worth that winner today I
mean come on that place was ridiculous
Adam what's your worth it winner
nice the cod worth it with a three-way a
worth our job now a three-way war that
winner doesn't yeah for part one we're
here in Australia we got more coming
lyndie wine with a steak she sells
seashells by the seashore she sells
seashells by the seashore oh yes